Eleven o'clock.
I didn't know it was so late.
Goodnight.
Goodnight, dear.
Oh, Bob!
You've got my gloves.
That's funny, there's a pair of gloves
in my pocket.
Are these yours?
Let me put them on for you.
Bob, I really must go now.
Goodnight.
And, honey, you will be on time
tomorrow night, won't you?
You were late tonight
and I was worried.
I'll try awfully hard, Bob.
Just drive down the street a bit,
I'll tell you where to go later.
I'll tell you where to go right now.
Police headquarters.
Go on, get up there.
Well, well, well, if it isn't Ritzie.
This is indeed an honor and a pleasure.
It takes so little to give some
people pleasure, doesn't it?
Where's Thunderbolt?
- Who?
- Don't try any of that stuff on me.
You know who I mean.
In case your memory
has suddenly left you,
let me remind you of Jim Lang,
sometimes called Jim Carson,
sometimes called... well, sometimes
called anything in the world
but always known as Thunderbolt.
I suppose that you've never even heard
of the Hellinger case.
Or the million-dollar
St. Louis Terminal job.
Or the time that he held up
the Iroquois Bank single-handed.
He's wanted right now by nine states
for bank robbery,
and there's two more that'd like to
talk to him on a little matter of murder.
Now maybe you can remember who he is.
Quit your stalling. Where is he?
I don't know what you're talking about.
Don't you try to Ritz me, Ritzie.
Where did you see him last?
I don't remember.
Oh, you won't talk, eh?
Well, maybe you can tell me this.
Who was the other half of the bench picnic
in the park tonight?
Bench picnic?
I was in the park tonight
but I was alone.
Your men must be seeing double, Inspector.
Oh, my men were seeing double,
were they?
Well, here's the other half
of what they saw.
I've had enough of this stalling.
You two have been meeting night after night
for months and I know it.
Well, supposing we have been meeting.
Being in love is no crime yet.
Maybe not,
but being in love with her
is apt to cause you a lot of trouble,
young fellow.
I wonder if you know
that she is the girlfriend
of the most notorious criminal
this state has ever known.
She's been a member of his gang
for two years,
ever since she met him.
I don't know
a woman in this city
that knows more about him
and his affairs than she does.
I know all about that.
That's all over now.
- Where's Thunderbolt?
- I don't know and I don't care.
- What do you do for a living?
- I work at a bank.
How would you like to lose your job
and maybe work in a penitentiary?
That's where you're headed...
You let him alone.
He's on the level.
He's got nothing to do with that crowd.
Listen, Ritzie, you're a smart girl
and you can save yourself a lot of trouble
by giving us a line on Thunderbolt.
You know we can make it pretty hot for you.
You've got nothing on me
and you know it.
If you had,
you'd have locked me up long ago.
I'm through with that mob for good.
Whatever mistakes I've made,
I've paid for in my own way.
What do you say, Chief?
Shall I take 'em down and book 'em?
Never mind.
You can go now.
Let her go.
Goodnight, Inspector.
And thank you.
Don't let that dame out of your sight.
Thunderbolt will go through an iron wall
to see her.
And we want to be there
when they meet.
There's always the chance
of nabbing him
as long as she's out.
Good evening, Mr. Th-Th-Thunderbolt.
I got your phone call.
- The the best in the house.
- All right, Oscar.
Check your hat, sir?
No thanks.
I never know
when I'm going to leave in a hurry.
I always like to have my hat be with me.
Say, boy, am I seeing right?
Is that Thunderbolt?
Does that mean
there's gonna be any trouble?
Maybe not.
I'm keeping one foot (unintelligible).
Say, (unintelligible) Thunderbolt?
He hits you with that big right soupbone
and just ruins you,
all in one little smackeroo.
That's why they call him Thunderbolt.
Say, one little piece of lead
and the littlest guy'
leave even
as big... The biggest man dead.
Say, why don't nobody take a shot at him?
Well,
the cemetery's full of them that missed.
Let's have some real service, Oscar.
And your r-r-regular order, sir?
Right.
What are you going to have, baby?
Nothing.
That means she'll have a chicken sandwich
and a glass of milk.
Y-y-yes, boss, yes.
What's the matter, Ritzie,
what are you sore about?
I'm not sore.
What good would it do if I were?
What are you looking at?
I'm looking at nothing,
and it's wearing a tuxedo.
Who are you talking to?
Stay right with him, baby.
Don't let him get away with anything.
You might be lightning
to a lot of people,
but you're just a wet match to me.
Say, you big bozo.
That ain't no way to treat a lady.
No?
Give me that gun.
So you don't like the way I treat a lady,
huh?
I ain't gonna wait
for that ham sandwich another minute.
I ain't hungry. Is you?
Oh boy, somebody better call an ambulance.
You wait till I get home,
I'm gonna tell my husband.
L-I-lady, why don't you stop?
- There's gonna be trouble in here in a minute.
- I'm all wet.
I told you he was gon' hit her.
- Take it easy, huh, be careful.
- Are they gonna shoot again?
- Snapper.
- Wait a minute.
Get back there.
Where do you guys think you're going?
Watch 'em, Jimmy.
I wanna go home.
Sit down.
Hey, the two of you men,
clean up this mess out here.
(unintelligible).
Everything all right, chief?
Tough crowd here tonight.
Yeah, how do you feel tonight, Snapper?
Oh, fine, chief.
Hello there, Ritzie.
Have some nuts.
Great for the system.
Fills up the body.
How about your mind?
What do we do with her, Snapper?
Oh, drag that cluck outta here, will ya?
A couple of yous guys.
Let me help you, Snapper.
Hey, lay off that, will ya?
That's my trigger finger.
What a fine night this is.
Oh, uh, listen up, boy.
Oh, uh, oh, uh, get out of here.
Music, boys.
I suppose you thought it was funny
starting that ruckus.
Strikes me you could stand
a little cooling off.
How would you like
a dose of it yourself?
Go right ahead.
I wouldn't put it past you for a minute.
When night is creepin'
and I should be sleepin' in bed
What are you trying to do, baby,
get me sore?
If you were peepin'
you'd find that I'm weepin' instead
Jim, I'm going to quit.
What, again?
I mean it this time.
I've been trying to tell you.
I'm not going on with it anymore.
- I'm through.
- Night after night
Through with what?
What are you talking about?
All this.
These people.
You.
No one can fill
that vacant chair
We're going to have this out right now.
When you're not there
No need to knock,
the door is open for you
-Please, daddy
-We'll find a place where we can talk.
Come on.
Daddy, do you have to roam so very long?
There's lots of other new sheiks
who would like to be sheikin'
Come on, baby.
Daddy, daddy, daddy,
won't you please come home?
Night after night, I'm or yin'
Daddy, won't you please come home?
Daddy,
won't you please come home?
I'm so lonesome
No one can fill
that vacant chair
Home isn't home
if you're not there
No need to knock,
the door is open for you
Sweet daddy
Even the clock keeps tickin'
Daddy, won't you please come home?
Daddy, do you have to roam so very long?
There's lots of other new sheiks
who would like to be sheikin'
Haven't slipped yet,
but I'm liable to weaken
Daddy, daddy, won't you please come home?
I don't get you at all.
You tell me you want to step out tonight,
go somewhere that's lively.
I risk my neck
by walking into this joint,
with all the cops
in the world on my trail.
There's a 10-to-1 shot
there's a couple of dicks
shadowing you right now to get to me.
It's all right with me.
I can take care of myself.
But I do all this,
I take this big chance,
and your idea
of the way to behave
is to start that foolishness
all over again.
What's the big idea?
It's just this, Jim.
I want to be decent again.
Well, babe, you've always been
the most decent kid in the racket.
You know, I used to get a big kick
out of being your girl,
out of knowing that
you'd take a chance on your life
just to see me
for a few minutes.
You're the swellest girl
I ever knew.
You wouldn't want to keep me
if I didn't want to stay, would you, Jim?
Wouldn't I?
I'd keep you with me
if the whole world didn't want you to stay
and make them like it.
That's just it.
I don't want people to respect me
because they're afraid
you'll crush their heads
if they don't.
I don't want the police trailing me
wherever I go.
I don't want people pointing at me
and whispering about me.
All this Ritzie talk, boiled down,
means that you...
You're ashamed of me, huh?
No, just ashamed of myself.
I want to know people
who are different from you and me,
people who lead decent, normal lives.
People who get up in the morning
to go to work.
Regular people.
Oh, don't be a fool.
I don't care what you call me, Jim.
That's the way I'm going
to live from now on.
I'm going to quit.
Well, let me tell you something, Ritzie.
Maybe I'd like to go straight too.
I haven't thought about it much.
Maybe I don't know how.
But as long as I'm going my way,
you're going with me.
You're all I've got
that means anything to me.
Do you think I would...
Oh, come on, let's have a good time.
You'll feel better
in the morning.
Wait a minute.
You haven't fallen for another guy,
have you?
- Who is he?
- There is no other guy, Jim.
It's just that we're through.
You and me will never be through, Ritzie.
Get that straight.
You're my girl and nobody on earth
can take you away from me.
Do you think you could hold me
if I didn't love you anymore?
That don't worry me.
It's the guy that tries to take you away
from me that's got the worrying to do.
Oh, I know, it would be easy enough for you
to get your gang to do anything.
That's one job
I wouldn't let anybody do for me.
Come on, baby.
Come on.
I'd get that guy by myself
if it was the last thing
in this world I ever did.
Uh-oh.
W-w—w-what... what's that n-n-now?
I told you this was gonna happen.
Hey, get off my foot.
Find that light switch.
Don't get excited, folks,
it's only a little raid.
Everybody who can stand to pitch
will kindly keep their seats.
Stand still there or I'll shoot.
Don't move.
I ain't movin', boss.
I've been pushed.
Where is Thunderbolt?
Come clean.
Where is he?
I don't know.
And I don't ever want to know.
I want you men to get this
and get it straight.
It's been two months since Thunderbolt
got away from you
and he's got to be found.
Thunderbolt's girl's been living up
at Young Moran's house for weeks
with the kid and his mother.
Don't tell me that that kid doesn't know
something about Thunderbolt.
Put the works on him.
He'll talk
when it's a question of talking
or being out of a job.
Mr. Corwin wants to see you, Bob.
Okay, Jimmy.
You sent for me, Mr. Corwin?
Yes.
Sit down.
Hello, Mom.
- You're late, Bob.
- Yeah, I stayed overtime.
- Hello, dear.
- Hello.
I'm so glad you're here, Bob,
we were worried.
Oh, I'm sorry, Mary,
but there's nothing to worry about.
Everything was all right at the bank,
wasn't it?
Everything was perfect.
Yes, sir, everything was perfect.
- Until about 4:00.
- What happened about 4:00?
Nothing much.
I just got fired.
That's why I stayed late
to turn over my accounts.
You're joking?
I'm not joking, it's the truth.
What was it, Bob?
What was the matter?
Nothing, Mr. Corwin and I just couldn't
agree on how a bank should be run.
It was on my account, wasn't it?
Don't be silly.
Tell me, Bob, I've got to know.
They just told me
I'd have to make a choice.
Either I'd have to give you up or else...
Or else what?
Just or else, that's all.
Well, I'm glad you quit.
I never could understand
why you wanted to stay at that bank anyhow.
I don't think there was much chance
for you there.
Wherever you go,
they'll always be finding out about me.
Let 'em,
there's nothing to find out about you.
You know, I always thought
you were too good for that place.
They didn't appreciate you.
Oh, don't start crying, dear.
You'll get your nose red.
A thing like this doesn't bother us,
does it, Mom?
We've looked for jobs before.
I should never have come here at all.
I knew it wasn't right.
What wasn't right?
Coming to live here
with you and your mother.
You've been wonderful to me.
And this is the way
I'm repaying you,
getting you discharged.
You're working yourself up
over nothing, Mary.
What if I do lose a job now and then?
What difference does it make?
Come on, let's all go out
and have a good time tonight.
Oh, Bob, your mother's
fixed a lovely supper for us.
The lovely supper will keep.
Bob is right.
What you two need is to go out
and enjoy yourselves.
Yeah,
we can't let a chance like this go by.
I may not get fired again
for a long time.
I've got some mending to do.
You children go along by yourselves.
Come now.
Come and get all dressed up.
There you are.
(unintelligible).
Did someone knock, Bob?
I thought I heard a knock.
There's no one out here.
Come on, get your hat, Bob.
Run along, dear.
- Have a good time.
- Goodnight.
- Goodnight, Mom.
Now, don't feel that way.
Nothing important has happened.
The thing that gets me
is that I was expecting a promotion,
and you know what that meant.
I'm not gonna wait any longer.
As soon as I get a job again,
we're going to be married.
There's no sense in waiting.
Well, if it ain't the long lost child.
Hello there, Ritzie.
Well, it was a long time finding ya.
I think you've made a mistake.
You made a mistake, baby,
thinking you could keep out of sight.
- Come on, Bob.
- So this is the old hideaway, is it?
Well, I guess you know Thunderbolt's
been looking high and low for ya, don't ya?
Why didn't you let him know
where you were?
Drop him a postcard or something.
I'm not interested in Thunderbolt.
You're not, huh?
And this is the Kewpie that made a sucker
out of Thunderbolt, huh?
Well, I wouldn't be in your shoes
for all the rice in China.
Stay on the level, Ritzie.
What have you been doing
with yourself all this time?
Take your hand off her.
Don't shove me.
I'll shove ya.
Well, I'll teach you to shove me.
Look out, Bob, he's got a gun!
Come on, Bob, let's go back upstairs.
I'd like to take another sock at that guy.
You've hurt your hand too.
Come on, Bob.
Did you fall downstairs?
- Why, what happened?
- He fell downstairs, the poor man.
I'd put a piece of fresh beef steak
on that eye if I were you.
Well, you ain't me.
My sister always puts a key
down the back of her neck
to stop a nosebleed.
I'll slip something down the back of
your neck if you don't leave me alone.
Where's the nearest telephone
around here?
Well, here,
don't you dare go near there.
Oh, I just hate to see anybody hurt.
Oh, now a squalling baby.
Why, what's the matter?
Nothing.
She talked me out of going out.
You've hurt your hand.
What's happened?
I guess I knocked it
against something.
What's happened, Mary?
We ran into a man I used to know.
He tried to get fresh
and Bob had to hit him.
Oh, I... I see, I...
Well, we'll put something on it.
- Don't bother, Mom.
- No, come on,
we'll wash it out
and put some iodine on it.
I don't want any of that stuff on it.
Took a week for it to
wear off the last time.
I don't want anything on it.
That water could be hot.
Mom, you treat me like I was a baby.
That's all you act like
when you're hurt.
Well, I ain't hurt.
You got me mixed up
with the other guy.
I'll bet you never touched
the other guy.
Yeah? Well, no mother'
be able
to fix him up for a long time.
That's what you say.
I'd like to see him to believe that.
Answer the telephone, Mary.
Mary, answer the telephone.
Hello?
How's every little thing?
I'll be coming up your way.
I can't, eh?
I'll come right down.
What for?
It won't make any difference
to your boyfriend.
You might as well say goodbye
to him now.
I just called up
to give you fair warning.
- Let's put this iodine on it.
- I don't want any iodine.
Now hold still, hold still.
Ouch. Ow!
Now look what you've done.
All over my clean floor.
I'll clean it up.
Not my towels!
Ouch.
Do nothing but buy towels for this place.
Look out there now.
You know I keep
the floor cloths under here.
Look at that iodine.
You never can get that up.
Well, I told you not to bring it out,
didn't I?
I'd like to put some on your...
Jiggers, Mom, I'm gettin' sore now.
Well, what do you do if you get sore?
Well, I'll show you,
I'm bigger than you are.
Yes, well...
- Give me the napkin.
- Not look, you'll get your hands all dirty.
Give me that rag.
I'm telling you, there's nothing...
Bob, now, stop it.
You're nothing but a big baby.
NOW Will you stop it?
Let go.
Say, Bob, now who do you think I am?
You're not fighting with
that fella down there!
Yeah, I'm working with you, Mom.
Stop it!
Bob, please! Ow!
Go on, get out of here. Beat it.
I can't find her.
Well, now don't worry, she's only gone
to the grocer's or something.
I know, but she's been gone
such a long time.
But here's her pocketbook and gloves.
- She'll be back soon.
- Now, I'm worried.
Well, I'm the one
that ought to be worried
with the dinner getting cold
and everything.
Do you think we oughta call
the police?
Now, Bob, don't be so silly.
She'll be back in less than no time.
Hello?
Katie! Katie!
Yes?
Are you calling me, Annie?
You and Bill better come right up.
The radio's working again.
I'll be up in a minute,
Bill ain't home yet.
Hey, listen,
I thought I told you to beat it.
Now, come on, go home.
I got work to do. Come on, boy.
Nice little dog. Come on.
Come on.
Come on, come on.
Come on, boy.
Come on.
Come on!
Come on, boy.
Come on.
Ain't he cute?
I just love dogs.
Come on.
Come on, get out of here, get out.
Go on, get out. Beat it!
Stay out.
Now, Bob, don't go near that door.
I'm not going near the door, Mom.
Come on away now.
There's that bark again.
Well, what if a dog does bark?
I didn't know there was a dog in the house.
Don't go out, Bob.
Please, for my sake.
Don't go out until Mary returns.
What are you barking for?
I thought I told you to beat it.
You're going for a walk.
You poor little mutt.
Go on home.
If you've got a home.
I've got no time to play with you now.
Put up your hands,
you're under arrest.
All right, put 'em up.
And keep 'em up.
Frisk him, Bill.
Slip the bracelets on him.
Get back up there.
What are you doing up here?
Go on, go wait upstairs.
Go on, upstairs, everybody.
Come on, keep movin' there, keep movin'.
Wait up there, now go on,
now get back up there.
Well, well, well, Thunderbolt.
Long time no see.
You guys are all alike.
No brains, no brains.
Your dame told us
you were coming here.
A lot of help you were.
To think it took a mutt like you
to send me up.
I didn't know you had a dog.
Is he yours?
He is now.
He cost me plenty.
Ain't he beautiful?
I wouldn't brag about him.
Come on, boys.
Let me go down there.
Let me!
What right have you got
to keep me back?
Just stay back.
Oh, Bob.
What is the matter, Mary,
what happened?
Go into the... go into the house,
go on, children.
I wonder what she's got to do with it.
I don't know.
Roll, Jordan, roll
I want to go to heaven when I die
to hear sweet Jordan roll
Brother, you ought to been there
Yes, my Lord
A-sitting in the kingdom
for to hear sweet Jordan roll
Roll, Jordan, roll
I want to go to heaven when I die
to hear sweet Jordan roll
Sister, you ought to been there
Yes, my Lord
A-sitting in the kingdom
for to hear sweet Jordan roll
Roll, Jordan, roll
I want to go to heaven when I die
to hear sweet Jordan roll
Roll, Jordan, roll
I want to go to heaven when I die
to hear sweet Jordan roll
Say,
this piano will need tuning pretty soon.
Yes.
I wish there were a way of telling
when a human being's out of tune.
Couldn't be more comfortable at the Ritz.
One-Way Street, huh?
Everything coming in
and nothing going out.
Now take care of yourself
and don't catch cold.
Plenty of blankets here.
And look out for pneumonia.
Don't want to give this place
a bad name.
Roll, Jordan, roll
I want to go to Heaven when I die
to hear sweet Jordan roll
Hey, Number 3!
Hey you, new guy.
You're Number 3.
You might as well get
me right from the start.
I'm Number 1 anywhere.
Well, Number 3 or... or Number 1
or whatever you are,
do you sing tenor?
Who me?
I kill tenors.
Oh, a tough guy, hey?
Too bad you ain't a tenor.
We had a swell quartet,
but they took our tenor yesterday.
Hey, Number 4.
What does that new bird look like?
Well, ain't much to be said about him.
Pretty big.
Got a mug on him
like they use to scare babies with.
Looks like he cuts his hair with a...
Oh, close your trap.
Say, is that you, Thunderbolt?
That's me.
Reading from left to right, Thunderbolt.
Who wants to know?
Don't tell me that you've forgotten me.
Wait, that sounds like Chuck.
Is that you, kid?
The kid himself, sure thing.
Say, what are you in for, big boy?
Being kind to animals.
I just got too interested in a dog,
that's all.
You know any more jokes?
This place is for killers.
Who is that, a friend of yours, Chuck?
Friend of mine?
I should say not.
How long you gonna stop in our hotel, Jim?
About eight weeks.
Anybody else in here I oughta know?
Holler roll for him, boys.
Joe Ripley, been here so long
I've forgotten what I'm in for.
Kentucky Sampson.
Caught on the 13th job.
I was that good, the jury brought in a verdict
of guilty before they went out to lunch.
I'm next door, Jim, Number 5.
Hey, Pat, give me a light, will ya?
Everybody talkin' 'bout Heaven
ain't goin' there
Heaven, Heaven
Gonna shout all over,
goin' to Heaven
Leave those matches here, will you, Pat?
I would (unintelligible).
Sure, you know it's against the rules.
And furthermore, my name is not Pat.
- What is your name?
- Don't tell him!
Make him guess!
Number 6.
Making my exit today.
I got a song, you got a song
All of God's children got a song
Number 7 is at the piano.
Special dispensation from the warden.
Number 8, (unintelligible) Roberts.
Murder in the first degree.
Brought up by honest parents.
At least, they was honest as far as I know.
Absolutely on the level
until my 12th birthday.
Number 9's still in the hospital, I guess.
Number 10, now broadcasting.
Bad AI Frieberg, that's me.
I guess I don't have to tell you who I am.
Maybe you should.
I never heard of you.
Don't kid me.
Everybody heard about me.
There was whole pages in
the papers when I was caught
Pictures and everything.
The Machine Gun Terror,
that's what they call me.
Oh yes, I remember you now.
The Machine Gun Terror, huh?
Well,
down my way they call you Squirt Gun AI.
I'll squirt gun you, you big stick.
If I ever...
Oh, you big fat head,
I bet you bragged your way into the joint.
Come on, Number 7.
Back to your cell.
As I was saying, I was absolutely
on the level until my 12th birthday,
and then, well,
nothing much happened until I was 37.
Then I blew up over a dame!
You're not the only one.
You said it.
There's a dame behind
every guy in this joint.
That was the trouble with me.
The dames wouldn't let me alone.
I wouldn't be here now if two skirts
hadn't fell for me at the same time.
Yeah, I know.
Fell for you, you mean tripped
trying to get out of your way.
Say, listen.
I've had about enough out of you.
I'd show you something if they let
me out of here a couple of minutes.
You big cluck!
What would you do, big boy?
I'd do plenty.
Don't you worry about that.
I ain't afraid of you or that
phony right hand of yours.
Sure you're not,
with these bars between us.
- Hello, Mr. Moran.
- Hello, Jack.
- How are you?
- Fine.
Well, what can I do for you?
Well, you sent for me, Mr. Corwin.
I did nothing of the sort.
That's funny.
Your secretary phoned the house yesterday
and left word that you wanted to see me.
Miss Randall has gone to lunch.
Is there anything I can do for you, sir?
No, never mind.
I don't see why she
should've called you up.
There's nothing I want to see you about.
Then I'm sorry I bothered you.
Got a match, buddy?
Take it easy, Moran.
Come on there, all of you,
get your hands up.
Keep 'em up!
High up there, face the wall!
Come on, do as I tell you.
Even a bank ain't safe
from these gangsters.
- Come on, come on.
- Hey!
Come on!
Sweet Adeline -Sweet Adeline
My Adeline -My Adeline
-At night, dear heart
For you I pine -For you I pine
-In all my dreams
-Your fair face beams
- Hello, Jim.
- Good evening, chaplain.
You seem happy tonight.
Just got some great news.
What would you call great news?
Getting out of here?
That doesn't worry me.
I've always paid my way.
What does worry you?
Maybe I can help you.
My Adeline
You couldn't help me with this.
I've got to do this myself.
For you I pine
Well, maybe I can help you some other time.
In all my dreams
Maybe you can.
-Your fair face beams
Come on, you guys!
Come and get me!
Get back, get back.
You men will only get me into trouble.
I'll handle this.
Watch me!
Now you turn over that gun
this minute, do you hear?
This is my last warning.
If you don't, we'll just
have to fill you full of bullets!
Go ahead, that's what I want you to do!
I don't care how I croak
as long as I beat you to it.
Bad AI Frieberg!
That's me!
Now listen, AI, listen to reason.
We've got to execute you tonight.
Besides, you haven't got a chance, AI.
That gun's empty.
- How do you know?
- We caught the guy who sold it to you.
I'll show you whether it's empty or not!
Ah, don't point that thing at me!
Bring on your gang.
I don't care how I die
as long as I die shooting!
Yeah, you'll die shooting.
Shooting off your mouth.
I'll get you too before I'm through!
You ain't big enough, little boy.
I'll fill you full of lead
if it's the last thing I do!
Yes, and if I was the warden I'd take that gat
away from you and shove it down your throat.
If I could only get close enough
to take a crack at you!
You haven't got the nerve it takes
to crack a slot machine.
Get out of the way, boys!
Clear the deck!
Give me that gun, you rat.
Give it to you?
I'll give it to you all right!
Rock-a—bye baby, on the treetops
When the wind blows, the cradle will rock
When the bough breaks, the cradle will fall
Down will come baby, cradle and all
Here's a souvenir for you, warden.
When the wind blows, the cradle will rock
Get the doctor!
You get back in your cell!
Go on now!
Down will come baby, cradle and all
Thanks, Mike.
My name is not Mike.
I'll guess it.
Just a little accident, doc.
Somebody hit him.
What'd he hit him with, a Sledgehammer?
Looks a like a very dangerous concussion.
It won't be fatal, will it?
Listen, doc,
you've just got to see that this man lives.
Do something!
I've got to execute him tonight.
Take him to the hospital
and put him on the table.
He's certainly had a terrible shock.
Be careful with him, boys.
You shouldn't have hit that man so hard,
Jim.
Don't worry about him, warden.
He'll come out of it in a couple of hours.
I just tapped him.
Well, anyway, I'm much obliged to you,
and if there's any little favor I could
do for you, that is, within reason.
Well, if it isn't asking too much,
I would like to have that
dog of mine in here with me.
Well, I guess we can
fix that up for you all right.
(unintelligible)
I thought I had that quartet broken up.
But I no sooner get rid of one
than they send me another.
You sure pulled me out of an awful mess.
It was a pleasure, warden.
I'd have been in a tough spot
if this thing had broken in the papers.
Think of the scandal!
I'll fix that dog thing up
for you in a day or two.
That brings me back again
Down home where I remain
Where my honey lamb am
I will be right there with bells
When that old conductor yells
All aboard, all aboard
All aboard for Alabam
Alabam, Alabam
Couldn't be more comfortable at the Ritz.
And don't you give me any trouble!
I'm having trouble enough around here.
I'll see you later, Number 4.
Hey, Number 4!
He's calling you, new guy.
You're Number 4.
What are you in for, new guy?
They were robbing a bank
and someone got killed,
and they found a revolver in my pocket.
You didn't have anything to do with it,
did you?
Not a thing.
That's fine.
Now tell us another bedtime story.
Hey, what does he look like, Number 3?
Swing around there, buddy,
so I can get a good look at you.
Don't be bashful, I'm not gonna bite you.
Well, he ain't so bad to look at, I guess.
He's got a face like those fellows
on the collar ads,
and I ain't sure but what
he's got a dimple or two.
Beautiful hair and kind of a mushy mouth.
Looks like one of those lady killers,
if you ask me.
The kind a silly dame is bound to fall for.
What's your name, new guy?
Moran, Bob Moran.
Moran, huh?
Say, ain't you the guy I been reading about
that stole Thunderbolt's girl?
Take me out to the ball game
Take me out with the crowd
Buy me some peanuts and Cracker Jack
It might interest you to know
the guy across the way from you
is a party by the name of Thunderbolt.
You two guys oughta know each other better.
One, two, three strikes, you're out,
at the old ball game
You put me in here, you framed me!
You know I'm innocent, you're in on it!
I'd like to get my hands on you just once!
Just once, just once!
If I never get back,
let me root, root, root
You've got me wrong, kid.
I've never done anything to you.
You're a dirty liar, you framed me,
you got me into this!
I'm not afraid of you, I'm not scared!
I'm not afraid to die!
Over, lay over.
Thatta boy, there.
Say, Thunderbolt!
If it's all the same to you, will you stop
teaching that dog to roll over and play dead?
He's giving me the willies.
Get the handcuff crew.
Hey, up there on the upper deck,
front and center.
Yo!
The district attorney wants to see you,
down in my office.
What does he want?
I don't know.
Well,
I don't want him bothering me anymore.
I got enough to worry about as it is.
Well, you haven't got much longer
to worry about anything.
So you've set the date for my kick-off,
have you?
Yup.
I've got two for the
week of January the 7th.
Who's the other one?
Moran goes on Monday
and you're set for Saturday.
That's great.
You know, I was glad that your lawyers
got you that temporary reprieve
so that you could be
around a little while longer.
You don't take it so hard.
But some of these other fellas...
- Come on, get him out of there.
- Hey, warden!
I may be seconds to death,
but you've got no right to make me listen
to that same piece of music
every time that band plays here.
It's cruel and inhuman.
I come here for rest and recreation.
You're just plain ungrateful, that's all.
I'm sorry you ever came here.
So am I!
Come on, bring him out.
Sit down, Jim.
How are you, McKay?
Let's get down to cases, Jim.
You know me and you
know the kind of a man I am.
Yeah.
I don't want to send an
innocent man to his death.
As a matter of fact, I'd fight just as hard
to get an innocent man out of here
as I would fight to put
a guilty man in here.
All right, I'll vote for you.
What are you running for?
This is a serious matter, Jim.
It'll pay you to be serious about it.
I may be helping to snuff out the life
of an innocent man.
You mean you're sorry for railroading me?
Several people have been to see me
about Bob Moran.
He's the man you were going to kill
the night you were caught.
I was going to kill?
You got me mixed up with somebody.
I make it a point never to kill any Morans.
Then why did you go
to his apartment that night?
I'll bite, why did I?
You tell me, you know everything.
That kind of an attitude won't help you...
I'm not looking for help.
When I want your help, I'll let you know.
Do you know this lady?
No, who is she?
Bob Moran is my son.
He's my only child.
I came down here to ask you
to help me to save him.
Well, I guess it's no use, is it?
What's the idea of pulling
this sob stuff on me?
Just a minute.
Oh, Mary.
Oh!
Jim, you're not going
through with this, are you?
What are you talking about?
I know you, Jim.
You're a killer, but you were always fair.
You were never mean.
You were never cruel.
Have I got to listen
to all this junk, warden?
No, not if you don't want to.
You listen to me, Jim.
You had Bob framed for that killing.
You said you would get him and you did.
What's the idea?
What are you trying
to frame up on me here?
I guess that'll be all, warden.
Oh, Mary.
Jim, those two women need that boy.
If there's anything you can say
that will help them, say it now.
Home, James.
I don't see how I can
win him off for you folks.
You mean,
you mean you won't reopen the case?
There's nothing I can do.
The only chance we had
was for him to confess.
But it was clear from his attitude.
- Surely you could see...
- Attitudes don't count, I'm sorry.
We need evidence.
All right, lock him up!
I guess you'd like to get close to Moran,
wouldn't you?
Well, you're not going to!
Why not?
I wouldn't hurt him.
Not much, you wouldn't.
I can't quite get your angle.
Aren't you satisfied he's
going to be executed?
What more do you want?
I don't settle my debts that way.
I'm going to get him myself.
If you ever get any closer to him
than you are right now,
it'll be over my dead body!
Dearly beloved, we are gathered together
here in sight of God
and in the face of this company to join together
this man and this woman in holy matrimony,
which is an honorable estate
and is not by any to be entered into
unadvisedly or lightly, but reverently.
Into this holy estate, these two
persons present come now to be joined.
If any man can show just cause why
they may not lawfully be joined together,
let him now speak or else hereafter
forever hold his peace.
Wilt thou have this woman
to be thy wedded wife?
Wilt thou love her, comfort her, honor
and keep her in sickness and in health,
and forsaking all others, keep thee only
unto her so long as you both shall live?
I Will.
Wilt thou have this man
to be thy wedded husband?
Wilt thou obey him and serve him, love,
honor, and keep him in sickness and in health,
and forsaking all others, keep thee only
unto him so long as you both shall live?
I Will.
Who giveth this woman
to be married to this man?
I do.
Repeat after me.
- With this ring I thee wed.
- And with all my worldly goods, I thee endow.
Those whom God hath joined together,
let no man put asunder.
I now pronounce you man and wife.
Oh, my poor children.
Oh, my poor children!
I'm sorry but your time is up.
You'll have to go now, Mrs. Moran.
Oh, my boy!
Just a minute, warden.
Let me be the first
to give them a wedding present.
Moran doesn't belong in here.
They were right.
I had him framed.
Jim.
You keep out of this.
I'm talking to the warden,
and get away from me
before I change my mind.
What did he say, dear?
What did he say?
He means that Bob is going to be free now.
You're to blame for this!
I've been in this racket now for 30 years
and this is the first time
I ever saw anything like this happen.
Four hours before an execution!
Before anything else happens, I'm going
to call up the governor and get a stay.
Maybe you better take my statement first.
I know what to do!
I've been running a jail all my life.
Don't you try to teach me my business.
Come on, you two,
you've just got to go now.
You'll have to leave now, madam.
I knew you'd come through, Jim.
Oh, leave me alone.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you, Mr. Thunderbolt.
Go on, close it.
You've done a wonderful thing, Jim.
Well, I've been here a long time now
and I'm shuffling off
at the end of the week.
I've had a lot of time
to think things over.
Better lie down, Bob.
Try and get some sleep.
I wanna speak to him.
I wanna thank him.
I wanna shake his hand.
We'll shake hands on Saturday when I go.
Hey, Thunderbolt!
What's the idea, you going nuts?
I thought you didn't like that guy!
A little music, professor.
Summertime, summertime
We will be together in sunny weather
Down the lane once again
Sweetheart, you and I!
Summertime, summertime
Wedding bells will chime
All will be sunny
Peaches, cream, and honey
In the summertime
Aw, now don't argue with me.
I just left Thunderbolt playing checkers
with Moran and I know what I'm talking about.
He had to get Moran reprieved.
He's always had his mind set on
bumping off this cluck all by his self
and this is the only way he could do it.
You guys give me a pain.
No imagination.
He's gonna wait until they opens up the
door to take him for the last walk, see?
Then he's gonna go over to say goodbye
to the boyfriend.
Now, get me.
I'm Thunderbolt and you're the kid, see?
They opens up the cell door
and starts me for the walk.
Then I goes over to say goodbye
to the boyfriend.
I sticks out the left hand.
See, boys?
This is the minute
that Thunderbolt's been waiting for.
Well, "80 long, pal," I says.
And then socko right through the bar.
All right.
Hey, wait a minute.
This invitation is for
last week's execution.
What do you think we do here,
give out rain checks?
Out.
What a heart.
Good for a hundred years.
It oughta be.
It's only been jilted once.
She's Mrs. Moran now.
Hey, gimme a light, will you, Timothy?
What's the matter, Moran?
Aren't you happy
now that you're getting out of here?
I'm not worried about myself.
I'm getting out in a couple of weeks
the warden said.
I'm worried about you.
Don't you worry about me.
Hey, Timothy, these clothes don't fit me.
Take a squint at them.
How do you think I'm going to look?
What do you care how you're going to look?
You're not going anywhere.
And my name is not Timothy!
Well, don't get sore about it.
I'll guess it before I'm through.
Come on, boy, we got
a couple of minutes more to play.
Whereas... give me your attention, Jim.
Whereas at a trial time on the...
You don't need to read
that death warrant to me, warden.
I know it backwards.
- I beg your pardon...
- Don't you bother me now
when I've got my mind
full of a million details.
- Yes, sir.
- Yes, sir, no, sir!
Yes, sir.
I knew I'd forgotten something.
What do you want for lunch?
You can have anything you want, you know.
All we've got to do is to bring it in.
Lunch, what time is it?
Three minutes after eleven.
What time is the big show?
11:20.
So you're going to give
me 17 minutes to eat it, huh?
Well, I'm not going to bolt
my food down in a hurry.
I'd have indigestion all afternoon.
I'll tell you what I would like to have,
warden.
Anything within reason, Jim.
- I'd like to have a good shot of...
- Nothing doing.
The only stuff we've got is in the hospital
and you've got to be sick to get it.
Well, I'm sick.
Who's got a better right to be?
You are sick, aren't you?
On the level, you don't feel good, do you?
I feel terrible.
I feel like I'm going to die.
Hey, guys, Thunderbolt
says he don't feel so good!
He feels like he's gonna die!
Well, I'll see what I can do about
getting you a little something.
How do you feel, Jim?
Same as ever.
The same as ever?
Yup.
You and me can't do any business.
I've lived all my life
without what you stand for
and I guess I'll have to die the same way.
You don't mind my sticking around
in case you change your mind?
Make yourself right at home.
Hey, Thunderbolt.
What do you want us to sing
when you're going to your dance?
I don't know, what have you got?
Well, how about Brokenhearted?
That oughta fit you like a glove.
There she is, my old gal
There he is, my old pal
And here am I, brokenhearted
How do you like that?
That's not so bad.
How do you like it, Moran?
Here you are.
You better take this, warden.
You need it worse than I do.
I certainly did need it.
You ought to be glad
you haven't got my job.
You have no idea what I go through.
Don't you worry, boy.
It's me that's going, not you.
- Everything all set?
- Yup!
Let's go.
So long, Shorty.
See you soon.
Thanks, Thunderbolt.
Send us a postcard.
Sure, "X marks my room,
wish you were here."
Jim, aren't you gonna say goodbye to me?
Me not say goodbye to you?
I'll be back in a minute, Moran.
I'm saving you for the last.
There she is, my old gal
There he is, my old pal
And here am I, brokenhearted
Mine in May, his in June
She forgot mighty soon
And here am I, right here
Brokenhearted
The last time that we said goodbye
I knew that she was through
It's bad enough that I lost her
I had to lose him too
There they go, feel their joy
Happy girl, lucky boy
And here am I
Brokenhearted
So long, pal.
I wish I could help you now, Jim,
the way you helped me.
Funny, sizing us two up,
nobody would ever think
you were the better man.
You're the better man, Jim.
You've taught me a let
these last couple of days.
You'll be seeing Ritzie soon,
won't you, Moran?
She's a great little girl, isn't she?
You were pretty lucky
to take her away from me, weren't you?
I didn't mean to tell you, Jim,
but I guess I will.
Somehow I think you ought to know.
I oughta know what?
I didn't take her away from you, Jim.
It was you that took her away from me.
I took her away from you?
We've always been sweethearts,
since we were kids, and then she met you.
I didn't amount to much
and she thought you were wonderful.
She never told me anything about that.
I guess I was nothing to brag about.
I always did have a peculiar habit of
taking things that didn't belong to me.
That's why I'm here.
You're kinda crazy about her, aren't you?
I love her, Jim.
Well, I guess I do too.
I still do.
Good luck, kid.
Good luck to you both.
Give her my love.
And take care of her, whatever you do.
Well, chaplain,
I might as well give you a break too.
Come on.
So long, old timer.
And don't take any wooden biscuits.
Hey, Dinty.
Come here, will ya,
and give me one more light?
Here, Dinty, I guess I'll quit smoking.
Thanks, and my name isn't Dinty.
And before you go, I want you to know
that my name is Aloysius
and you didn't guess it.
- Your name is what?
- Aloysius.
What did you say your name was?
Aloysius and you didn't guess it.
Who would've guessed it?
No...
He said...